[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world of
entertainment and pop culture news i'm
heather ruse and i'm i anna-wade and
this is your news for monday september
11th so it seems like every week we've
gotten a little bit of tightening
casting news and this week it's no
different we just found out that our
Hawk and Dove have been casted Alan
Ritchson will be playing Hawk and Minka
Kelly will be playing Doug on Titan so
we have that to look forward to yeah who
do you think they'll cast next I don't
know like every week seriously every
week it's like Titans Titans day coming
at you in other casting news Riverdale
is apparently adding Sabrina the Teenage
Witch to season two dove Cameron who is
best known for being on Disney's
descendants is going to play the Teenage
Witch on season 2 so it'll be a little
ah to see how they try to incorporate it
considering that the tone of Riverdale
is pretty down to earth angsty we're
gonna add magic that could be
interesting it could be a thing that
happens yeah it could be a thing that
happens also in other testing news we
have Bohemian Rhapsody coming out and
rami malek of mr. robot will be playing
Freddie Mercury I am very excited for
this I had so many questions oh my god
is he gonna sing if he does say does he
have a four octave voice range that
would be amazing right
I doubt it a surprise but it'd be really
cool and I'd be interested in seeing
that if he doesn't sing or doesn't have
it that well are they gonna dub him
right I hope not or maybe will they
downplay the singing and bring out more
of the story I don't know there's so
many possibilities but he looks
fantastic they have a side-by-side photo
I think on Entertainment Weekly that you
look at and he said the first time I saw
the photo the official photo of rami
malek it looked I thought it was Freddie
right I really thought it was a real
picture of him so he looked awesome just
questioning what he sounds like yeah cuz
acting wise he's great and especially a
mr. robot he he does some really cool
choices so acting wise I feel you buddy
I feel like you you're gonna come out
with something really cool but I'm
really interested to see how this thing
inside of this go yeah because it's I
mean it's it could go so right but so
wrong so fast so looking forward to
Bohemian Rhapsody I hope there's
Thunderbolts and lightning something
very very frightening me two more
trailers we saw this week in our
streaming kind of news here and I've got
magic school bus rides again that's
gonna be streaming on Netflix September
29th I'm super excited because my girl
Kate McKinnon is going to be playing
Miss Frizzles younger sister who's now
taking over the Magic School Bus and
lead Mount Manuel Miranda himself did
the theme song and it sounds incredible
and I love it yeah I mean I'm excited
for this too the only thing that I'm a
little weary of is I'm not a huge fan of
the art style mmm I'm not sure if the
revamped art style is my kind of thing
but I am excited for new Magic School
Bus especially as a teacher I'm like yes
more Magic School Bus
wait those some cosplay opportunity for
me I don't know no promises just more
maybe both of us but that's gonna hit
Netflix on September 29th and another
thing coming to net Netflix soon is a
new anime called neo yo Kyo and this
project sounds very interesting very
off-the-wall it's put together by the
frontman of Vampire Weekend he wrote
produced directed the whole thing and it
stars Jaden Smith of all people Jaden
Smith
he's like this bored demon hunter who is
also like the most eligible bachelor and
all of me okie okay go and also a demon
hunter because that's how anime is roll
classic anime right right so it's
supposed to be baby semi satirical but
also kind of serious and they made some
really good collaboration with a studio
production i.g which is a huge studio in
Japan um so a lot of the concept art was
done by the same artist who did a Gundam
Unicorn and rurouni kenshin so they have
some really good animators involved on
this project so it's we saw the first
trailer it looks insane I will probably
check it out because I'm interested to
see where in the world this thing is
going is it also be more cast to it -
yeah you'd lost Susan Sarandon bunch of
other people yeah the casting is insane
it looks insane it seems like it's gonna
be very postmodern hipster cool chic
funny question I don't know if it's
anywhere near Avatar The Last Airbender
anime style story wise I don't know it
would be worth checking out at least
right so that drops on September 22nd if
you're just as curious as I am check it
out on Netflix so also this week we saw
the trailer for a Star Trek discovery
which is going to be streaming on CBS
all access and that comes out on
September 24th I'm excited because
Anthony Bratt more Broadway voice coming
into my world to get them and I love it
I love it so much so I'm very excited to
see where the Star Trek goes especially
since this past week we had Star Trek
day yeah yeah it's the 51st anniversary
it's okay I'm not that old so I can't
really say old so yeah um this week it
felt like we had a ton of director news
coming at us so one of the first things
that we saw this week is Gavin O'Connor
is officially slated now to direct
Suicide Squad to which we all asked for
yes we all want that but I think that
this is gonna be a good fit with the
universe and where they've been going
with it I mean he just finished
directing or came out with the
accountant which fits that gritty style
and also starred Ben Affleck so
apparently he's got some connections
there so I mean it'll just be a good
kind of safe bit it'll feel similar I
think to Suicide Squad the original but
maybe with less colors I don't know just
seems like a safe a safe choice really
Alissa Dion listen Eon just as much
great yeah
we also found out that Drew Goddard is
going to be directing the x-force film
so it's interesting to see kind of which
characters they decide to do I mean I
don't know like there's so many ways
they can go with it so we really have no
other information on this film right so
let us know down below what kind of like
directions that could kind of take with
this movie and what you're looking
forward to
I'm excited they're making an exports
button right right be interesting should
be interesting yeah we'll just have to
wait and see um also this week it was
announced that Colin Trevorrow
he's no longer directing Star Wars
Episode nine yeah so that also comes on
the heels of a couple of months ago them
firing the director for the new Han the
directors for the new Han Solo film and
hiring Ron Howard instead it just seems
like Disney might be moving towards a
more safe direction maybe getting some
of those new directors that they had
initially hired out for something
that'll be more safe and reliable and
there's no official news yet on who's
gonna take his place
there's been a ton of names tossed
around but no one has been officially
reattached to the project yet so we
don't even have
confirmation on if it was an amicable
departure from the film it sounds like
there's many stories right so who knows
why or who will take its place we can
only speculate so speculate wildly in
the comments down right right I gotten
they've been a ton of name tossed around
like JJ Abrams was one tossed around and
who knows not even Disney now also this
week we heard that Futurama is coming
back two more episodes in the form of a
radio play love it
yeah and so they're producing it along
with the Nerdist so it's going to be
released on the Nerdist comm it's also
supposed to be a companion piece to the
mobile game that came out so it'll be
dropping on September 14th on the
Nerdist comm and it is with the original
creators and some of the cast so you can
look forward to more Futurama hijinx
everyday it's Friday also I hope it's
super heartbreaking because that's
Futurama thermate man they got got me
right here all the feels so we'll see
I'm very excited yeah very exciting I'll
definitely be tuning in mm-hmm well I
think that's about it from us here at
the orbit report Heather where can we
find you on social media well you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse or
Instagram at a truce or twitch.tv slash
Heather is awesome and then me as usual
you can find me on Facebook at Ayanna
Wade or everywhere else as awesome
Ayanna very easy to remember
spelled down below go find some check it
out talk to us about any of these things
we've talked about this week cuz we're
very excited for so many things coming
out and that'll be it for us so we will
catch you next week so
[Applause]
you